I am attack Elena at Mitaka Leena on
Twitter so please follow me just so that
you know and I'm trying to eat 10,000
followers by the end of the year so
please help me into that that release
that my son so I'm here today to talk
about nodejs
streams and the future of Nod streams
and you know how you can help or maybe
what you can provide feedback on so a
couple of things first I work for a
company called near form we have a nice
booth in the booth CRO we are also doing
some raffle thing with some smartwatches
and air foot so come by oh they you know
we donate some money out of the Ottawa
charity out after the booth after after
that so please come by swing by would be
interesting so we are not yes we are a
professional services company that do
all things javascript so you know if
you're if you have some problems with
your javascript and you need some help
and your team need some out likes please
pass by we have a lot of things to talk
about so conversation so let's go into
into streams okay how many of you view
snowed streams I mean if you have like
node streams okay a few maybe I mean if
you understand those streams okay I'm
not sure I trust you
[Laughter]
so a stream is like an array but over
time essentially instead of having a big
chunk of data enough of memory which
iterating upon your receiving data along
the way and your processing them over
time this is fantastic because it
enabled us to crunch an insanely high
amount of data with a limited amount of
memory which is fantastic right that's
that's what why there we are using them
we are using them for file processing
and a lot of other things so there are
key part the problem is that node
streams are really complicated and most
people don't really understand all
dreams at all by even some cork not core
contributor struggles a little bit into
when it comes to those two reviewing
those crispy PRS it's really you know
it's a really complicated code base that
evolved a lot over time and you know in
fact it emits about number of events so
not streams are based on having to meet
parameter and they emit a lot of events
you know you can have the data event you
probably have used you have you that is
the readable event which probably you
haven't used much because that's not
very popular that is close this is a
meaning this end that there's some other
meaning different from close by the way
you know there is finish which you know
close at the finish you know they kind
of mean the same thing right no they're
truly completely different tree
completely different meaning and then
that is destroyed to tell the full thing
the full thing down and I have not
mentioned error because you probably
have known that emitting every node is a
really big thing so there is also that
to take into consideration
just to recap data and readable are for
reading data and that close and then
finish are emitted when when streams are
ending to some extent the meaning of end
it's on the readable side the meaning on
finish on the writable side so when a
readable stream is done or the writable
stream is done successfully successfully
only so if there's an error or an abrupt
operations are not emitted close is
emitted when the underlining resource is
brought down and it will be emitted also
in the case of fibers so so once upon a
time the only way to interact with a
stream was by using the data on data
event you will find a lot of these
examples everywhere okay this I call
this the wild horse example because
essentially you are receiving as much
data as fast as the source can provide
you which turns out to be a very bad
idea because you cannot really you know
it's really hard to pause the source to
some extent enters a please slow down
because this is too much data I don't
know what to do it with that here
also take into account that Jesus posted
the source of one of the wars back ever
so if you put with will is it okay if
you put a sink here you are creating
making a lot of pop card so don't put a
sink there James has a talk tomorrow
about broken promises go to his broken
promises talk because it's a really good
talk to be to go and dig but pressure
with that on data model is really hard
because I'll do you stop there's a pause
method on strings but pause is only
advisory so so at some point it was
introduced a new in another API called
the readable event to actually you know
provide a pool based model so instead of
having these fire rows of data okay let
me just call you and get me notify me
when there is data available and then
let me read that data from you so
instead of you know a fire hose of
information is more a pool model
okay so streams can have a push model
and a pull model I'm implementing in the
same codebase how does that sound
that's it's are able to maintain okay
but these is actually the probably the
best way to interact with the string
because you actually can you pull data
from it so you use the internal buffer
in the most optimal way still again not
really this is not really readable to be
honest it's also more performant because
in this way you only read the data that
you need so it's a little bit more it's
a much more gentle in the buffering off
of the streams error handling is still
super complex though streams and this
probably the one of the source number
one of memory leaks and file descriptor
leaks file descriptor lists are really
fund to to diagnose so this is now this
is how to not stream a fight over HTTP
don't do this okay
how many of you have done this few
people don't do this at all this is
community this will create a memory leak
immediately y-you can you see who I can
this create a memory you know can't you
see the super is it's obvious right it's
a fast that's a simple API out what can
I write bad you anyway
so if you if you look at this you see
these PI press so if the response errors
or quit or the and the other side close
the connection the read stream is not
closed or till now or destroyed so it
stays alive and stays a light forever
because then there is nobody to consume
that string and that's that's a big
problem so essentially if in your code
are using pipe without having some
special error handling magic you're
probably of a memory leaks and where
your application so don't use dot pipe
what you need to use is pipeline which
is a new operator that we have added in
north core I think ten or something or
eight maybe even eight I don't ten ten
anyway it's available on as an open
source model under the name pump and
these Souls released inside the readable
stream model module anyway there is
pipeline and pipeline is actually really
cool because it actually feared player
down the streams so if one of those
errors it close all the others so
basically it makes sure that there's no
memory leaks and no leaks of any sort so
please use pipeline okay don't use pipe
you might want to ask why can't you
change the behavior of pipe to actually
do the right thing well backward
compatibility we cannot break everybody
okay there's a lot of code that the
light of that behavior out there so you
can we can't really change that that's
bad you can also use a framework by the
way to serve files pretty probably the
best option is actually to use a
framework because there are a bunch of
things to be done so don't survive
manually you just use a framework you
will do it for you it will do the right
thing actually so use a thing
note that all the best features nodejs
are based on streams so as good as best
as it sounds it's an aging codebase that
is a lot of history and although jes
repents of this a fast depends on this
HTTP depends of this HT picchu of course
and a bunch of other stuff so standard
input a standard output dependencies
things so it's really important to
understand and evolve this code base in
them in the best way without breaking
everybody because the biggest problem
with developing note stream in node core
and somebody field an ogre collaborator
will tell you that if you touch those
you can really break everybody so don't
break everybody there is a one bit big
problem though you know because the
JavaScript community use a sink await
everywhere now how many of you use async
await good everybody is there somebody
that do not use any async await at all
we can probably have a beer afterwards
right anyway so everybody has moved to a
sink await the biggest problem with
streams and the sink away it is that the
two things do not really mix well
together and if you try to do that we
are probably have seen some new promise
and then doing some shiny guns to get
actually the thing to do what it what
you want to do I don't know you probably
somebody as soon is nothing I hope I
hope it I'm meeting some nerves here but
the outer do it is not clear is not easy
and it's not straightforward so
essentially you have we're not doing a
good way of serving you folks that's not
core contributors into this by the way
I'm part of the team that maintains the
node streams so member anyway so we
cannot really change the things that are
already there without breaking everybody
because everybody depends on these
things so for example we cannot really
change all the streams work because then
it will break whatever web framework
that you are using
those used streams or you can change
them if we break some of the file
processing that you do so we can do some
surgical changes but we can't really do
much so so then the question comes how
can you improve the usability of this
usability of streams considering the
fact that you know people love us in
Kuwait so the first one was the number
one mistake that people do with streams
is on data sync don't do that okay
right now I'm working on a fig go to
this totally but I'm going working on a
fix I did a PR to help with that but to
actually provide some safety net but the
net result would be you will have a
memory leak if you try to do that and so
the thing that I've been working on for
the last few years he has been to
provide a sync iterator support on on
streams how many of you knows about a
sync iterators hey fantastic guys
the best feature that has been put
putting inside one of the recent we
should have note they came into node it
said note 10 so that basically after
December by the way no date goes out of
maintenance in the 31st of December this
year so stop using no date so since
January 1st all supported version of
nodes yes we'll have a sync iterators in
which is fantastic so we can use them
everywhere depending on whichever node
version we are using how does this look
like well you have a bunch of things to
say so first one up is you can have an a
sync generator of amazing generator this
is actually a very specific way to write
a function that you know can spit out
things you know that you can iterate on
like this with for await and you pass an
iterator now what you probably don't
know is that there is a full protocol
under that thing you know to power that
so you can write your own a sync
iterators without using the the function
syntax for example more or less like you
can write your own iterator normally the
resource for
other objects so you can if you want to
use for off into on an object on any
object you can actually provide that
type of capability because there's a
protocol so there is your your object
need to implement certain methods to do
things so this is pretty interesting can
we use this with streams
well maybe we when this was being
standardized we were working with tc39
to actually validate that we could
actually use them with streams and we
could so so things are compatible and
compatible right now so you can use this
code right now so you don't need to
write any turn on any flag and so on
this code is so you can create your
stream and then you can faraway it and
iterate over that stream pretty cool
right and you can just process those
chunks and that's it and when the for
loop ends it ends hey I don't need to
use any crazy events I don't need to do
any shine against I don't need to do
anything crazy
I just can't just do my thing and don't
be done with it and note that if I break
I use break from my for loop it just
tear down the streams automatically
again I don't have to do anything about
it so it just dude they just end up the
very 80% basic use cases that you need
and use the down the other API is as
low-level components also in node 12 but
also not 10 now these are shipped on
node 10 as well so I need to update
these lights in node 10 in all version
of node but it was just recent
recently ported to not 12 so like the
last release of no time we have added
readable dot from which essentially you
can pass you can pass a an iterator or a
nursing calculator to readable dot from
and it will automatically convert you in
to a stream which is pretty fantastic so
you don't have to do anything now okay I
can just use I can just use these to
convert
to convert us to a function or an object
or an array to a stream so it simplifies
a lot of testing for example because you
need to test your streams right I hope
all of you write unit tests if you don't
write unit tests go start writing any
tests so you can and then use pipeline
always use pipeline so with now you can
also go and write some crazy you know
concept of Inception so you can start
with an a sink sink generate on function
convert into a stream and then iterate
over the stream now these are some
little side effects okay stream one of
the key concept of streams is data
buffering in order to a stream in order
to be performin is to will buffer data
and so you're a sync generator will get
cold a little bit more up to fill the
streams buffer so it has a slightly
different behavior than these would be
have a slightly different behavior that
are normal if you just iterate over the
scene generator still is doable and you
know you can use these things to
actually level the field up it's pretty
fitting nice because then you can just
accept a parameter if it's a sink I
terrible and just a sink iterate over
that and you can use an assassin
assassin generator or any other object
that implement that protocol and your
code will actually be the same so it's
pretty powerful it's pretty powerful
okay so it's demo time
so hopefully the demo gods will be with
me you know because that's that's an
important piece so I have a seven
examples I'm not sure if I go through
all of them we'll see so this is the
first example so this is old-school
streams so you implement the red with a
the youth pass you implement the read
method and with read you just you know
iterate over a big array and just push
all those values in and then push now
this is how you would do implement these
things a long time ago so you run this
and you just spit out of the code
right now this was how you would do this
thing note that you knowed we change I
changes this and not these will not run
on note six it not six this won't work
by the way okay we have fixed some stuff
I do not think this won't work
whatever don't try that or not six of
course that is long gone so we don't
have to worry about it anymore
so now let's go and look at another
version of the same code so this is just
using readable from know that we see use
on data to put to process that to
process the data however in this case we
just pass the array through and we just
get a stream back this is really
powerful for for testing for example
because in this way we can be compatible
and so on without you know breaking a
sweat so we can run this code and you
will still see you can still work the
exact same now what you can do is you
can also go into the full inception mode
to some extent and you can pass in a
generator generator function know that
this is all synchronous okay a generator
is synchronous a sync it a sync
generator it's a synchronous okay anyway
you can do this and you can still run it
and you still get this amount with it
before but now you're generating it from
a function instead this is pretty useful
again we can of course use those with we
can use we can go from an iterator to
Anna sync iterator using this API so we
can pass we have we have at the our
generator here we pass it to readable
from and then we a sync iterate over it
why because it's all pretty much generic
so we can still run the code in still
spitting out 1024 numbers a lot of
fantasy so as I said we can also go full
inception mode and do the sync iterator
to a sink iterator thing okay note that
if I do like let's let's let's show this
so this still runs not that if I do
instead it will still do exact same
thing okay we still work the exact same
so there is as I said there is a little
bit of difference related to how much
data is fetched from the sync iterator
function so there is that thing to take
into consideration but that's that's it
so now you can also given that so those
are streams though so you can also call
all the full api's so for example if you
have a if you have a five you want to
read from a file and we want to read as
it as as text as shrinks you need to set
the encoding and you set the according
to a utf-8 and it will still work now
let's run six it spits out the same file
yeah a lot of hard magic here and note
that when you do this then you can do
whatever processing you want in here so
for example if you do by the way always
use promise if I if you want to get
promised version of anything don't do it
manually the chances if you did make a
mistakes doing manually or some of your
colleague will make a mistake
after you have done it correctly six
months later it's very high so don't use
promise advice that is there for a
reason and it's also really fast so we
go with generators Lib function with set
timeout there are a pretty a lot of
nasty things that you can just for if
you just forget a return in your new
promise thing you will just create a lot
of poppers and memory leaks and very bad
things so avoid again broken promises
and you know we can do an a quick await
here for of this you see now is taking
some time and note that this is
interesting okay
do you know why is the single chunk
yes because it's read as a full Sun from
the disk interesting right
so if we do the same thing in in here
okay if you do this the same thing in
here
yeah
you will see that now it does what God
says on the tin
okay note that if you do it in in that's
- okay I want to correct one note that
yes I'm going forward so anyway last
thing is that they want to show you it's
an example on the server okay
note that when you're using a singer
wait on the server you also always need
to put a catch handler in there make
sure make sure that if you don't put a
catch and ER you are going to create a
memory leak everything about you called
make promises safe the name implies the
name is exactly what it implies or you
crash on and handle rejection this is a
big conversation and it's not the focus
of this talk but if you run your code
with no an Android section enter and you
don't crash on and handle rejection you
probably have some memory leaks in your
code very likely anyway just always put
a catch under when you are moving from a
known a sync function to a promise based
function or a sin function so what we do
here we just count the chunks and count
the length and and then we just here we
just use the request module - to do two
pipe things so I'm just running this up
and you see this is all working fine and
it's actually really fast note that
[Music]
using a sync iterators is actually
really fast as prolly faster than using
other things you know using gun is as
fast as any other way of processing
streams in not so use that that is
doesn't have a big performance overhead
I we have optimized the sync iterators
like to the bone problem so it's the
vehicle the code is really nasty from in
there just I brought the things
so let's go talk a little bit on what is
missing so the first one that is missing
is how to write a transferable stream
using a sinc iterators so there is for
example something that you could use to
actually process the data along the way
this is actually a very nice idea
because we can have transfer by and you
just pass in an a sinc iterator a sync
generator function that except on a sinc
iterator as an input so it has these all
its own morphic input and output and
then you can just for await the thing
and just yield the results so it's a
pretty nice pattern to write a transform
a way to transform data pretty cool
right I love this so and then if you
convert this each to a transfer stream
then you can use it with pipelining
interact of the stream secure system
modules note that this is currently work
done so hopefully this PR will land
again it means it got stuck at the
meaning of tober so I'm hoping to
unstuck it this weekend we have the
collaborator Summit written in two days
so hopefully I can get that unstuck and
you can get that landed eventually I
would love to be able to create a to
avoid creating a transform completely so
you can just pass in a single a sink a
sync function I think I think I think
generator function that essentially
implement that pattern for you so in
this way you know you can do avoid
creating another stream you can just
compose function as much as you like
it's pretty it's pretty interesting this
is not implemented yet this is fantastic
code I'm living in wonderland now
hopefully this will eat your screen
maybe on node 14 hopefully we'll back
ported them now I've talked about
readable I've talked about transform now
I'm talking about writable you know I
haven't talked about writable at all at
this point
writable well I don't know what to do
with writable that's the end story
and you know if you want to write
something to write something you need to
consume asana sync iterator right
however you want to have an operation
that actually you know returns are
freaking promised the problem the fact
that you know our current right thing
does not return the promise and it's
very hard to create the behavior to
return a promise why well in this code I
would like to be able to write this code
okay look at this this is we have write
a bill right and then we do a way to
write chunk now this code is correct
however all the magic is in bill right
the problem is in the error ending model
of promises virtual streams streams emit
an error event as soon as it happens
promise is like quantum physics so they
will error only when you look at it
that's a net that call parts of the
problem so managing and this is why
using promises with streams is really
hard because one thing in errors
straight away the other thing around
only when it when you look at it so
those two things are really really hard
to mix and match and you can see this
this code that does this kind of
shanigan to make this happen so
essentially we are we are registering an
error event and cashing the error you
know I'm cashing the error so that
whenever you and we return with this
right function will return a promise
that you know when you look at it will
error okay it's really bad it's really
bad code so I don't have anything better
than this so if you have any ideas any
promise expert that wants to give it a
shot I am really welcome to to to
brainstorm things this is still open
so how does it all work well almost is
implemented in JavaScript so you can use
all of this stuff in your code learned
the pattern and use it for other things
so I think iterator as I said I'm
running a little bit out of time so
whatever hope you don't kick me out so
or not this is an extract from North
core so essentially we are implemented
the symbol ADATA sync iterator primitive
that returns a function and essentially
we just create call that call our
generator for that our builder for that
and we get a turn on us in Kotori so
essentially it's in order to prove to
build something you just need to provide
that note that if you want to build and
I think iterate or you can you should
use this type of pattern if you don't
want to use on a sync generator function
that is nice and really cool to use but
if you want to do some of the hard stuff
that we're doing or providing the
mapping that we do in note 4 what you
need to do is that you need to create an
object which as the prototype of the
sync a traitor
and and implements a method like next
and return next when it's called one
night is called to get the next element
when the return is called when you exit
that's it there is some other few but
they are less important these are the
key to once so internally not core we
wrap the readable event these are some
consequences and one of those thing is
that is there it's really performant so
that's the good side also it handles it
windows while buffering and and all the
things this is a long link sorry
when small is the source of the
implementation now I'm going to open it
up for you ok and I'm going to open it
up and just do a quick scroll he choose
200 lines of code
ok not that bad not that much but really
lot of very ugly stuff in here sorry
lots of edge cases and ok so there is no
performance penalty in using a single
raters over the other method so that's
the key part which if you talk about
promise based API saying there is no
performance penalty this is pretty big
and I'm not
find and underselling Elizabeth
typically promised best a far lower than
code back best ah this thing is on par
just so that you know one last thing
before I finish there is what woody
streams now what would you stream says
what you're using in node fetch okay in
a certain uh keynote file using in fetch
in the browser not in not fetch not not
does not have what would you choose
now this creates a little bit of abyss
compatibility between the two things
this is what we do streams were which is
this pipe to method three complex again
okay all the key part there is streaming
is real streams based API are really
complex you know and you know if you
want to implement those you need to
implement this thing which has a number
controller and a lot of other stuff
which is really complicated again
so not really easy and I just want to
skip through this but we would like to
have those in North core and to make it
more consistent you probably seen my
stock so this makes us some sense to
have this in North core however we want
to be compatible with the node ecosystem
we saw we use node streams at what time
is here the next one okay a tree okay so
I think sorry
however what with these streams are
going to be a sync hi interval so that's
cool they implement the same pattern so
I hope one day to be able to do this
type of thing which may we start from a
water G readable and then consume is
just using an a sync generator function
pass to a not writable and it will or or
fine so we're all the introduction is
being managed by via their sync I
traitor protocol which would be pretty
fantastic do you want to get involved
please reach out I will be at the booth
so reach out to me the next few days if
you're interested in you know stuff you
know those questions again we are near
forum again this is a raffle the blah
blah blah okay
and thank you
[Applause]